foreign
Elizabeth is with us in Cincinnati hi
Elizabeth how are you
how are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
uh well first off I've loved the book
and I loved meeting your daughter Rachel
a couple of years ago well thank you
and our oldest son is the one who
introduced us to Dave Ramsey and after
we've seen Rachel we went home and we
got busy
and
we are me and my husband both will be
turning 60 next month
and we have seven children who are now
all out the door yay and yeah
and
we have really worked really hard
we were very late in starting 401ks
once we started doing all of our savings
we had a couple of catastrophes in our
house
which we had to Do complete remodels
guts bathroom and kitchen because of
black mold so it wasn't beautification
this was health issues
so goodbye savings
and
at this point we only have
a house payment
one car payment
with sixteen hundred dollars left on it
and after covid
my husband took a 10 cut in pay lost his
bonuses and with the remodels that we
had to do we
I budget everything I use spreadsheets I
we use cash allowances but I'm to the
point now
I'm my husband has turned over the
finances to me so I don't want to
disappoint him I want to keep him on the
same track
so my question is
we are late getting our 401K but we have
a hundred thousand
we owe 73 000 on our health her house
will not be paid for until we're 72.
and we have a eight thousand dollar
credit card bill because it's a medical
because our savings was gone
do you have any savings that's not in
the 401K
we have six thousand okay which book did
you read
The Total Money Makeover and I've had to
start over yeah
you needed both of you get the book out
because number one he turned the money
over to me no
well I know no no no no no don't don't
well me no just know no the two of you
need to sit down and make these
decisions together you don't get to
carry this by yourself superhero you
don't get that privilege the two of you
need to make these decisions and carry
this weight he doesn't get to bow out
like a coward and say oh whatever I'll
just he didn't get to do that either no
so what does he make
he makes 113. what do you make
yeah I kind of
parents
are you still
yes I am are they paying you
and I'm one of them does good okay so
you get you need to get the book back
out and start working back through the
dead snowball leave your 401k alone get
the stupid credit card paid off the
stupid car paid off and then let's build
an emergency fund and then let's put 15
of our income away and then let's start
working on paying off the house and both
of you need to do everything you can to
maximize your income and I want your
debt free house and everything in five
years you can do that